[Music]
hello everyone
uh so we'll continue from
where we had left of last time so we had
managed to find out
this uh this integration with the ddt in
front
uh rewritten in terms of this uh this
particular
integration and as we had mentioned last
time
the plan is to substitute this
particular term
back here and
and then proceed so we'll do exactly
that so
what we have now is rho dv dt
is equal to rho b
plus tds
the surface integration and this can be
rewritten
by taking the volume integrals to one
side
we take the row common
dv dt minus b vector
dv is equal to the surface integration
e vector ds now
in order to establish the connection uh
between the between the traction vector
and the stress
which was our original plan what we'll
do is we will apply
this equation to a very special kind of
geometrical figure
and the motivation for that will be
movement will be it will be clear
uh in a moment uh after we have actually
drawn this figure so let me first of all
draw
the the tetrahedron and
uh and then you will see
now why you are considering this kind of
a special figure
and please note that this special
tetrahedron
is is written is drawn and explained in
almost
all the textbooks of mechanics of solids
are
irrespective of the fact whether they
mention the connection with fluid
mechanics or not
and i believe that even in your feed
mechanics you did come across this
tetrahedron
but but we'll draw it again and we'll
proceed with the explanation nonetheless
okay so
so first of all we set up our coordinate
axis like this
let's say this is our x1
x2
x3 and then let's draw a tetrahedron
here
okay uh let's name the vertices like
this
so
this is o this is
a this is b this is c
okay now
our plan is like this we will consider
each of these triangles triangle abc
triangle ocb
triangle oac and triangle oab
individually
and we are going to consider the unit
output normal to that
separately as well as one generic
traction vector
lying on that plane so first of all for
our triangle abc
so let me draw this unit outward normal
depicted by the n-hat
the traction vector on this let it be
denoted by
this fraction vector
now what i will do is i understand that
very formally this fraction vector will
have a dependence on the position vector
of the point on which it is being drawn
as well as on the unit outward normal to
the plane on which it is being
considered
however in order to to have a little
less
clutter as far as the writing is
concerned
i will only i will i will assume that
the dependence on the position vector of
a generic point is implicitly understood
and instead write only the explicit
dependence
on the unit outward normal like this
and i will write a little shorthand for
this in this fashion
so this will be considered to be equal
to t hat
t vector subscript n
so this is for the triangle abc
next for the triangle ocb now you note
for the triangle ocb the unit outward
normal
will be along that direction
okay will be parallel to the o a or the
o x one
but oppositely directed now
suppose we were considering the x y z
coordinate system
instead of x x1 x2 x3 then our
unit output the the unit vectors along
the three coordinate axis would have
been i
i hat j hat k hat which we are all very
familiar with
but we are not doing it we are keeping
it general in terms of
x1 x2 and x3 correspondingly what we'll
do is
we'll say that the the unit vectors
along
o x 1 will be
e 1 hat along o x 2
will be e 2 hat and along ox3 will be e3
hat
so
for the triangle ocb the
unit outward normal will be along what
direction
will it not be equal to minus e1 hat
the unit outward normal to ocb i repeat
will be minus e1 hat it will be opposite
to this
let me draw that
this is minus e1 hat
the traction vector it will be along
some generic direction
let me just denote it like this
so this traction vector will be
dependent
on minus e1 hat this you understand
now if you go back a few slides
you see that when we had the dependence
on the minus n hat
it happened to be equal to minus uh
the same fraction vector but depending
on the positive unit outward normal
so t vector of minus n hat is equal to
minus of the t
vector of plus n hat we'll use the same
concept here also
so this will be equal to minus t
vector e 1
hat and that will be considered
to be equivalent to
in the shorthand notation that we want
to use
as minus t vector
subscript one within bracket next we
consider
the triangle oac
so the unit outward normal to oac will
be
along minus e2 so
this is minus e2 hat
and the traction vector
again will be along some arbitrary
direction
and this you understand will be
depending
on minus e2 hat which should be equal to
t vector sorry
minus of the vector
into hat and
that should be equivalent to minus
e vector subscript
okay
all right sorry about that finally for
the triangle
oab we'll have the unit outward normal
to be
parallel to ox3 but oppositely directed
so it will be minus
e3 hat
and the traction vector will be along
some generic direction
so this is p vector
minus e three vector equal to minus
d vectored depending on positive v3
and that should be equal to minus t
vector depending on three
subscript three okay so since our plan
is to apply this balance of linear
momentum equation on this tetrahedron
and i had said that there is a certain
motivation for it you quickly note what
is that motivation
the motivation is actually very simple
when we consider this
kind of a tetrahedron we are
deliberately considering surfaces
like oab ocb and oac
which happen to be perpendicular to the
coordinate axis under consideration
so our coordinate axes are ox 1 x 2 and
o x 3
the triangle ocb have the the
geometrical figure of the tetrahedron is
such
that the one of the planes constituting
the figure itself
is perpendicular to the coordinate axis
similarly for
the two other triangles oab and oac
this uh this will actually enable us to
uh to establish the connection between
the traction vector
and the stress components in a very nice
fashion okay so in order to go forward
uh we do not actually have to worry
about the
calculations of these or the
computations of these integrals
because we are going to use a nice a
very neat and clean mathematical trick
to evaluate these to these for these
integrals
okay so the trick is like this
we are going to use the uh what is
referred to as the
mean value theorem for integration so
let me write that down very quickly
for applying the
the balance of linear momentum
equation the tetrahedron
we'll use the
the mean value theorem
for integration
and you will see when we actually do
this application
uh that this will that the mean value
theorem for integration will actually
make our life
a lot easier but before we actually go
to that step
let us quickly uh let me quickly state
the mean value theorem for integration
not like a mathematician
but rather like an engineer in a very
simple uh
clear to understand fashion so what
we'll do is
uh instead of considering this this is
overly complicated geometry let us first
of all consider a simple one-dimensional
geometry
one dimensional domain may be flying
between x1
and x2 so forget about all this
tetrahedron all this balance of linear
momentum let's just consider the mean
value theorem for integration
uh so suppose we are interested in
evaluating this
this integral of f of x over dx
this definite integral of course
where the domain lies between x1 and x2
now what the mean value theorem or
integration is telling us
is that this definite integral is simply
the value of the integrand
evaluated at some point within the
domain between x1 and x2
inclusive of x1 and x2 multiplied by the
size of the domain so the size of the
domain for this one dimensional example
is simply x2 minus x1 so you see what is
this
the first part f of x star is simply the
value of the
integrand evaluated at some
specific point within the domain which
is given to us between x1 and x2
note that x star could be
x1 could be x2 also okay so the
the edges are allowed okay
next uh
suppose we extend this one-dimensional
idea uh
uh we extend from this one-dimensional
domain to a two dimensional domain
so maybe next we consider a surface
integration
so let us consider this kind of a
genetic position vector
and integrate it over this surface
so what the mean value theorem of
integration will tell us
is this will be equal to
the value of the function at some
specific
point the r vector star denotes the
position vector of some specific point
lying within the domain of consideration
within the s
multiplied by the total surface area
okay so so you understand
that here the x star
it belongs to x1 comma x2
closed interval here
the r vector star it belongs to s
and similarly for a volume integral
so these are some very generic examples
to illustrate the
mean value theorem so this will be again
the position vector
of some specific point within the volume
the given volume
multiplied by the total volume and with
this idea
uh we will proceed towards the towards
the application of this balance of
linear momentum statement
uh equation to this uh this
tetrahedron and we'll do that in the
next part of the
lecture thank you